well I was a hairdresser for many years
I actually wanted to be a hair and
makeup artist from quite a young age and
I've got a nephew who actually is three
years younger than me and for most of
that poor boys younger years I was
making him up as women and Aunt Sally
mostly and worse or gommage various
other characters from TV so I definitely
wanted to get into makeup from a young
age makeup in here is very hard to get
into it's not easy I work free for many
years I did theater I did voluntary work
a lot I did lots of weddings would I do
photo shoots for a photographer to get
my folio up to up to scratch I trained
to be a hairdresser and then worked in
the West End for four years and various
salons and then decided eventually to do
a makeup course because every time I'd
go on these hair shows I'd always end up
watching the makeup artists and I was
sort of more fascinated by that in a way
and actually somebody contacted me and
asked me to do a film and I thought why
not it was all set in the 80s and I
thought why not I'll give it a go and
then I just kept getting getting offered
work which was you know toured very
lucky
but that same designer kept me on for a
few years and yeah and I just fell in
love with the film industry
I loved creating characters you know
having a script and breaking down the
characters and a character's journey
within that I think the first thing you
need to do is you have to be you
definitely need to work in a salon you
have to be a very I would say about
three or four years where you're doing
all kinds of people's hair don't stick
to one ethnic group do everybody so that
you feel a tremendous amount of
confidence my main film that I worked on
had a bit of experience almost Kenneth
Branagh's Hamlet I was very lucky to get
on board that and work for three months
with some fantastic people you know
learning all about the hair I've worked
I was on the unit with the French French
girls and was their kind of little
assistant such as for a few months I
remember coming into the tent and seeing
that you know the makeup side the hair
side because you know I was I didn't
know split at that point you know
on the big shows I didn't know what to
expect to be honest to you but
definitely in all of that that scale and
how it all worked for sure and one of my
Jobs was a mascara watch making sure no
the ladies put mascara on because it was
a period drama and in those days I
didn't wear mascara so I was having to
go around to make sure that nobody none
of the extras put makeup on was my first
task I got into it basically through
Stanley Kubrick really I guess I was
sort of taken from I was doing a lot of
fashion stuff and then he asked me to
work on a movie and called Eyes Wide
Shut and then I was there for two years
I didn't really have a choice that carry
on doing either doing what I was doing
or go back to what I was doing so but it
was a great experience
when you first get a job the first thing
that you do is you're gonna read the
script once you're done reading the
script what I of course I'm gonna have
my meeting with the director and in the
process of that they're going to
sometimes they give me clues them on
what they want to do on most movies that
they because the wardrobe department is
normally hired before the hair
department and the production designers
are hired sooner
well I normally work with the director
the costume designer and and obviously
the actor as well and sort of you know
group them all together and sort of
decide on colors lengths and start
working working that way you know what I
mean so everybody is sort of happy so
taking all the information that
everyone's looking for you take into
consideration someone's look someone's
they shape next neck and all those sort
of things whether they can actually
carry carry the look there's no point in
doing a haircut that looks sort of
ridiculous if they're meant to be
playing a great beauty or something so
you have to be take all those things
into consideration you cannot really in
the hair department design any actors
hair without seeing the clothes first
the club the hair is sort of the
crowning glory to the clothes and it
will tell you everything about what
somebody should be if you did the hair
without the clothes you you wouldn't
even know what the character was but I
think that's important because you're
creating the whole character and I've
always thought you know
Hera's like a great accessory you know
you know can either finish it or you can
sort of throw something off a bit and
and always think you know if the heads
not really right for the character or
for the costume it can be quite a bit
disturbing we have to work very hands-on
with an actor because you have to make
the actor feel like their character so
really when you were not there to sort
of make them always look the best of
their ability a lot of the time it's not
fashion or it's not beauty you know
sometimes it involves breaking somebody
down and making them look like they've
been in a fight or they've been you know
disheveled or muddy so sometimes it's
not actually about bringing the person's
best features out but very much you've
got to work with an actor to make them
feel like their character or feel like
that character's journey and so that
it's a very different challenge
depending on the job you're doing mmm
weeks of the hardest thing I think to be
honest with you because well they cut
their costly and they sometimes can look
you know not as good as what you know
because with high definition you can see
wig lace so they're always an issue I
think I think it's nothing worse now on
television if you see a wig lace I said
I think people are always room in a week
and it distracts it is distracting it is
hard work and I think a lot of what you
do creatively as a person your pride and
your ego comes into it a little bit
because everything you want to do you
want to have approved and you want
everybody to love what you do and it's
not always the case and it's not
personal it's never personal from an
actor it's never personal from a
director but I think the best advice I
could ever give anyone is to be a team
player you have to be a member of a team
within your department within a crew and
and really not take things personally
when people criticize your work or want
something to be done a different way
it's it's for the for the good of the
job and not you know because you've done
something wrong you know it's very
incredibly long hours it's incredibly
hard work because you're normally there
before the rest of the crew sort of
getting set up and getting ready or even
staying afterwards to work on wigs or
hair pieces and something but you've
you're doing a period piece and there
may be a lot of Heric pieces of all
things involved you know there's a lot
of work are
do you rap so I think work experience to
see whether you've it's the right thing
for you so you can start off as a
trainee and work your way up to an
assistant but if you get on a good
production you can learn such a lot and
you have to work hard a good junior
isn't worth its weight in gold because
you start off maybe not so pleasantly
hands-on but you know you do make coffee
you do make tea you look after the
actors you do continuity which is a big
part of a show organization you learn
very good organization skills - it's all
part of the job you have to work fast I
wouldn't suggest going into it if you
know good in the mornings that's for
sure I mean you know you have to wake up
and you know sometimes you're up at 3:00
4:00 in the morning hours sometimes you
feel like a science experiment because
you you're up you know you they pull
back on hours where we are normally
first in last out it's it's you know you
can't moan you can't you can't you know
you don't think about ever going home
because that's kind of its it's the job
you know but then you've got a good team
of people that's why you have a good
team that you all should get on and you
work as a team and you have that that
connect that sort of bond I think you
know
the principles of what we do are pretty
much the same as they've been for 80
years you know I mean they were doing
this kind of prosthetics in a way on
things like The Wizard of Oz and even
earlier them oh I mean there's millions
isn't I mean absolutely absolutely
millions one of my favorite films I love
Lorraine Lorraine Margot you know
foreign film period drama beautifully
done